out on air live webinars from Google
Cloud we were hosting webinars every
Tuesday my name is David rachac and
today I will be talking about cube flow
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers standing
by to answer them let's get started so
as I mentioned I will be talking about
cube floated a cube flow is a brand new
machine learning platform designed to
make using machine learning very very
easy on kubernetes and the reason we
really approached this problem is
because we heard over and over again
that customers are looking to take
advantage of the great kubernetes
platform and all it provides relative to
cloud native applications and bring
those same kind of innovations to
machine learning
before I begin getting into cube flow
specifically a lot of people ask you
know what's so great about machine
learning you hear about it all the time
it's in the news you hear about all the
great new things that are coming out and
people want to understand doesn't
machine learning affect me can I use
machine learning to change my business
and the reality is you really really can
what you see here is a graph of Google
Data Centers and the amount of energy
that they use per the amount of compute
that they create these are data center
engineers who spend their entire life
getting fantastic at tuning data centers
making sure they run properly making
sure they are as efficient as possible
they use all the latest technologies
they use 100% renewable energy and they
really really spend all their time
focusing on how to make our compute to
provide queries and Google cloud as
efficient as possible when the team came
together they said what do we do next
they looked at machine learning and as
you can see here simply by applying
machine learning they were able to save
40% over already the best tuned data
centers in the world and that's exactly
what machine learning does you know when
when they first saw these results they
shook their head they couldn't really
believe what was going on but this is
the largest expense they had and they
were able to do that through standard
machine learning techniques however
machine learning is very hard people
under
and the standards of programming and
computing and how to roll out systems
and they've been building those
experiences over the past 40 years but
unfortunately the reality is is that
there's a big separation between all
that ml goodness that you heard on one
side and where people are today they
don't know whether or not it applies to
what their their current business
problems are they don't know how to make
those applications work and they don't
know even once you roll out those
applications if they can really diagnose
what's going on into the hood because a
lot of ml can be really inscrutable why
is it so complicated it's basically
because it comes down to these two
situations today there really aren't any
great prepackaged ml solutions and
there's a whole bunch of reasons for
this but basically it comes down to one
of the two following things either one
you have to set up your entire system
from scratch that means integrating with
legacy systems that means customizing
picking and choosing different solutions
and eventually once you spend all that
time getting your system in exactly the
right size and shape
you then have to migrate it because your
business needs change maybe you need to
move to new geo or locality maybe you
have data in different locations and you
want to run your machine learning in
different locations all those problems
now surface and you have to reset up all
your systems and reintegrate with a
brand new set of legacy systems or the
alternative is you use a entirely hosted
solution and in the first five minutes
that's great you get a first look at
exactly what machine learning can
provide unfortunately the next five
years are nothing but pain because you
have everything that you had on the left
you have the same issues setting it up
you have the same issues integrating
with your legacy systems and when it
comes to migrating you're now out of
options because you're locked into a
single deployment and certainly not all
hosted solutions fall into this category
but certainly many of them do because it
in the purpose of creating those hosted
solutions they've abstracted away a lot
of the customizability and
configurability necessary for really
production izing your ml workloads so
the question is haven't hurt we heard
this story before and the reality is we
have before
I came to work on kubernetes Rx's Mian
on cube flow I worked on kubernetes and
in 2005 out of 15 when we first got
kubernetes up and running we heard this
over and over and over again relative to
containers and kubernetes people were
building their own bespoke orchestrators
their own bespoke ways of rolling out
containers especially in production
ready ways and integrating them with
their legacy solutions and figuring out
how to get across clouds when kubernetes
came along it really enabled us to build
cloud native applications and when we
say cloud native applications we say not
just giving you all the components in
the box in order to do service discovery
and manageability and declarative
application rollout but really
extensibility about six months ago at
cube con Austin we had a talk
specifically about the extensibility of
kubernetes what this meant is you get
very clean layers in between all the
ways that you roll out your application
meaning that if you want to extend in a
specific way
you're able to use the native api's
without forking the code without having
some bespoke you know hardwired welded
together solution you're able to use
those components and extend it in the
way that make the most sense for your
business and what this ultimately
resulted in was cloud native apps these
are applications designed to run in a
distributed way they're loosely coupled
together meaning you can swap in and out
yet they're extremely scalable they're
designed to handle the realities of a
modern data center and modern
application the single node goes down it
knows how to recover if you need to
migrate from A to B it knows how to do
that if you need to use core components
like service discovery or mounting
storage you can handle that as well and
it allows you and your software
engineers to focus on just the
components that are the most important
for you the things that actually make a
difference for your business so what we
would propose is that we need the same
capabilities relative to cloud native ml
we the same loose coupling the same
scalability the same portability and for
us like I said it does come down to
those components we want it to be highly
composable we want it to be highly
portable and we want it to be highly
scale
my composability we mean you know
everyone focuses when it comes to ml on
building a model you might hear this
over and again a brand new paper came
out about you know detecting diabetes
and you know just through retinal scans
improving the way that that energy
deployment is used and and all the
advances you get they're discovering a
new protein through exploring space
those are fantastic models but the
reality is is that when you go and talk
to any data scientist they see that the
problem is much much larger it goes
beyond just building a model to the
actual end-to-end stack of building an
overall deployment that includes data
ingestion transforming the data
exploring it splitting it finally
building your model and then validating
that the model is accurate and then
rolling it out to production something
that very frequently is is overlooked
how do you roll it out and track it how
do you make sure it doesn't drift over
time how do you make sure it's better
than what you have out there today that
is what we were talking about when we
say composability we need to provide all
those components to really allow you for
a production ready environment and
especially because every Enterprise is
going to be slightly different one team
might use spark another might use to do
but another might use their own custom
data processing you might use tensorflow
you might use PI torch Cafe MX net it
doesn't matter or rolling out to
production you know whether or not
you're using kubernetes or your own a
potentially a hosted model serving all
those components are complicated and we
want to give you the ability to natively
choose the things that make the most
sense for you
secondly it comes to portability when we
think about portability this is the
reality of the world that entire stack
that I described earlier that is just a
component of all the configuration that
you might have you have runtimes drivers
OSS accelerators all under the hood let
alone all those compositions that you
have are above however you know once you
spend all that time getting your
experiment up and running and and so on
then you have to roll it out into a
variety of different environments which
might be very very different you
something for experimentation something
completely different for on-prem or
cloud-based training and then finally
potentially rolling out to the cloud
public private on prem for actually you
know serving it and integrating with
your application so that becomes more
and more challenging because all that
configuration you did in one environment
now requires a second set of effort to
go and replicate it for these new
environments and then finally we think
about scalability a lot of people when
they think about scalability it might
just be more nodes but it's actually far
more complicated than that you can think
about you know whether or not using CPUs
GPUs Google's brand-new tensorflow
processing units more CPUs per node are
you using those properly disk networking
concerns and then there's things that
are not just Hardware how do you scale
up for skill sets potentially you know
an intern to a data scientist a software
engineer researcher any of those various
things
those are scalability components as well
you talk about teams you know are the
teams geo-located are that does the team
grow shrink over time and then finally
number of experiments you the most
sophisticated machine learning shops are
in fact running thousands of experiments
simultaneously testing them off each
other and seeing what's working and then
tracking those experiments over time all
those fit fit into the components of
scale so those are the three key
components that we want to bring to
cloud native ml and as I said the things
that are great at that we already know
it's containers and kubernetes except if
you want to use machine learning on
kubernetes unfortunately you have to get
really really smart and a whole bunch of
things containers packaging service
endpoints scaling on and on and on
these are all new concepts even for the
most sophisticated application teams and
now layering kubernetes on top of that
is a lot for ml sign and data scientists
to grasp so that is why we introduced
cube flow the idea behind it is to make
it easy for everyone to develop deploy
and manage portable distributed machine
learning on kubernetes and for us it
like the following the first is you
think about kubernetes it provides a
wonderful abstraction layer and a set of
core services and native api's available
and then you describe your deployment
for Kube flow using code and you're able
to roll out the exact same deployment in
all these places so that complicated
pipeline that has been customized
exactly as you like is now swappable for
any of these environments based on your
needs and specifically you know two
weeks ago at koukin in europe we were
pleased to announce cube flow 0.1 our
first official release of our new
platform specifically in the box today
we have a jupiter notebook and
specifically jupiter hub we offer the
tools for multi architecture distributed
training meaning you're now able to use
many nodes and many accelerators on
those nodes in a very straightforward
way we also offer multi framework
serving so you're able to serve things
like extra boost and and tensorflow
and so on using standard components in
the box we have a number of different
examples and workflows and best of all
that last point we use case Annette
packaging to allow you to customize it
for yourself so with that I'd like to
show you a brief demo of what cube flow
looks like to solve a real-world
business problem one of the most common
things that people use today is around
sentiment analysis so this might be
where you have a large body of data that
you want to or a large variety of text
to choose me that you want to scan over
and process for understanding how your
business is reacting to these various
things I've recorded this video a little
bit earlier
unfortunately training takes a little
bit of time and we have a short time but
I'll walk you through exactly what what
we do so here you see this is the Yelp
data set it's published on kaggle and it
has all many many sentiments excuse me
many many comments about various
restaurants and things that might people
might want to use and you can see here
if we looked at this middle thing you
know it's a lot of text and standard
text analysis might not get at what
you're looking for in this case little
on the pricey in but the
goods were good and that's particularly
hard because you use the same word
meaning two different things in a single
sentence and so for that middle one we
would probably say wow that's actually a
good review that we should probably see
what happens so if I walk forward and I
look at how it's wired into our
application you know we'll go and we'll
click on the sentiment and unfortunately
it looks like we're way off and and this
is not at all uncommon you know you'll
you'll have something where you have a
coarse way of approaching a problem and
even though the you know a human can
figure out what's going on it might be
very complicated if we go and look at
the code this is not so good you know
we're just using standard machine
Eric Sydney we're using standard
techniques to look through for synonyms
of things that are good and things that
are bad let's see if we can do better
right now what I'm gonna use is
something called tensor two tensor this
is a standard machine learning framework
open sourced by Google it is designed to
solve a lot of these problems where you
can basically take a large bodies of
text paint them with sentiment analysis
say what's good and bad and roll them
out to solve some of these problems in
this case we've already packaged it and
you can see here that it supports
sentiment analysis and what we'll do is
we'll roll it out to cube flow
specifically so one of the most common
situations that we have today is a data
scientist might not even have a
kubernetes cluster available to them
what they want to do is they want to
start on their local laptop and figure
out how to explore a particular
sentiment or excuse me a particular
model to see whether or not it'll solve
their problem so right here I'm
executing the command this simply says
to my laptop I want to focus on using
mini cube mini cube is a free to use
local kubernetes deployment that lets
you test out a number of solutions
before you roll them out to production
so with that I'm going to take this and
I'm going to apply mini cube flow core
this is something where we have the
hosted in registry and this is the core
components that exists as part of cube
flow and we
that that's it that's the single command
that I need to execute in order to spin
up kubernetes our excuse me a cube flow
deployment you can see here after that
it gives me a Jupiter hub which is the
standard interface for doing a number of
machine learning exploration I go and
I'm able to select from a number of
different pre-built solutions in this
case we have all these various different
versions of tensorflow
GPU CPU support and I'm able to straight
through this configure it using various
CPUs memory and extra resource limits
including things like accelerators again
we're trying to make this very very easy
to begin using tensorflow
and with that I now am going to take
that deployment and like I said I'm not
going to do that show you the training
because unfortunately it does take a
little bit but locally what I've done is
I've downloaded tensor to tensor and
I've started running it and what you can
see here is that though I deployed cute
flow which is very straightforward what
I want to do is I want to configure it
based on my local environment and in
this case I've been able to say using
parameters without changing any of the
code I can say well look this machine
doesn't have a GPU and I only need one
worker that's the way of running these
actual applications and so on and so
forth so using parameters not changing
code or changing different packages I'm
able to set various things here and then
I'll take this and I apply it and now I
begin the job of training it's looking
at my local data set it's looking at
those nodes and you can see now with
just three commands I've gone from
nothing to a cube flow deployment to now
actually running a model in a very
straightforward way and you can see here
that that the model is running
appropriately so with that because it's
a laptop that's not going to Train very
quickly but I can see that there's no
syntax errors everything is working
properly so I think it's appropriate
that we actually take this and now
reapply it to the cloud before I began
this demo i created a kubernetes cluster
using google kubernetes
engine this is the overall framework
design our excuse me the overall hosted
service that we use to host kubernetes
made compliant clusters on Google Cloud
and in this case I'm going to use a
native feature inside of Google
container engine excuse me kubernetes
engine called node pools node pools
allow you to create multiple sets of
nodes that exist within a single
kubernetes cluster and it lets me
schedule all my jobs to the nodes that
are appropriate in this case I'm going
to create one node pool that has four
nodes each of which have eight Nvidia
Tesla P 100's and that I'm also going to
create a second node pool that we're
going to use for scheduling our TPU jobs
you can see there the 8 Tesla P 100's
associated with those nodes and then
we're also going to create these TP use
GPUs are Google's tensor processing
units those are designed to run tensor
flow particularly quickly and you can
see them that they are scaled up right
now so with that we are we're going to
go and we're going to switch our
configuration so now again without
making any changes I switched from
looking at my local cluster to looking
at the one in the cloud and now I'm
going to apply that exact same
deployment to the cloud and it's gonna
spin it up and run it from there
we're going to roll out our job to that
again we're gonna use distributed tensor
flow but before I do that I'm gonna swap
out those parameters as you might as I
mentioned earlier before we said we're
not going to use any GPUs now we're
gonna have one GPU per node we're gonna
have two workers and we're gonna roll
this out and it's going to use a
different dataset or excuse me a
different data directory instead of
using local and there you go so now
again you didn't see that you saw it
literally everything we had to do we
change some parameters and we changed
our context and we were able to roll out
the exact same thing that we add locally
to this cluster in the cloud to have it
run much more quickly we've made one
more swap we had a pre-built
cluster 40p use that you have to build
differently based on GPUs versus TP use
and we'll roll that out as well and so
again we just added one more command and
now we're going to run simultaneously
experiment simultaneous experiments
against both the TP use and GPUs as you
can see here we're walking through the
kubernetes our google kubernetes engine
you can see the logs running there and
you have the native support for showing
all the jobs that are running in your TP
you cluster oryx's me in your google
kubernetes imogen cluster now to see how
things are running we're gonna swap to
look at tensor board tensor board also
comes as part of the core set of
components in in cube flow and your you
can see here that on our GPU cluster
we're doing about you know two to three
experiments per second which is
perfectly fine for a large data set and
then we're gonna swap and and after
looking at the GPU one let's look at the
TPU one and on the TPU one we're
actually able to get it much faster
we're actually doing about sixteen times
a second so we're able to run that
experiment and see that that in this
particular case we get about a five
times acceleration of moving from GPUs
to TP use now that's not always the case
GPUs may work better for certain cases
TP use might work better for other cases
but what the power of cube flow is I was
able to experiment with those various
deployments without making any
significant code changes just changing
some parameters and and recompiling and
I was able to get get that so now we're
gonna do one final thing we remember our
goal here was to provide sentiment
analysis you can see there we deployed a
brand new server to take advantage of
that model that we have now trained and
we're gonna go back to the Yelp text and
see how we did you can see remember you
know happy sad happy was not accurate
let's see what happens when we swap it
out and we have to predict predict and
it works fine and so now again in a very
straightforward way using very standard
models that are published out there we
were able to train on our data set this
Yelp result reviews and
see a result that that you know improved
our overall application so as you saw a
very clean very straightforward way to
deploy machine learning to a variety of
different locations based on your
business needs and based on the hardware
and software that you have available to
you what you didn't see was anything
bespoke I was using native open source
technologies to solve these problems
using standard machine learning models I
was able to deploy and and what that
means is it greatly reduces the amount
of time your software engineers your
data Pro your data scientists your IT
pros have to spend customizing and
building their solutions together you
also didn't see any cloud specific non
portable technology the exact same
deployment I had locally ran on the
cloud and all I had to do was change the
parameters and finally you didn't see
any forking of the kubernetes api's this
isn't something where you need to go to
your IT pro and say they have to like
take all the software that they've spent
rolling out to make it very easy to
deploy their applications using
kubernetes and change it under the hood
- sup now support your brand-new machine
learning workloads this uses native
kubernetes api x' and really we are at
the start of a brand new world here we
want to use data to save lives there was
this wonderful story out of Sweden where
a bunch of data scientists looked at
their hospital records and they
discovered that women and stay-at-home
parents were being injured at a
disproportionate rate after new
snowfalls by looking at what happened
they realized that by doing nothing more
than changing the plowing schedule for
those particular situations after new
snowfalls they were able to plow
sidewalks before roads and what that
meant was that they were able to save
lives and reduce injuries and that's a
wonderful story because that's really
what we're trying to unlock with machine
learning and cube flow we want to give
people who are not experts in data
science the the intelligence to make the
difference for their overall solutions
and for us that means we want to swap
for
you know give nurses and civil engineers
and professors all the information
necessary for them to understand what
you know is affecting their world and
how to make better decisions using this
data so finally we are just getting
started you can see here there are a
number of different folks who have
contributed to the cube flow platform we
announced cube flow in December at cube
Con in North America and over the past
six months we have been stunned with how
quickly it has grown it over 700 commits
71 different contributors 17 different
companies you can see some of them here
who are already contributing the
platform and we really do want to make
this an open platform that is designed
to run everywhere as you saw we went
from laptop to Google container engine
we support anywhere you are running a
kubernetes compliant architecture on
Prem in the cloud on your laptop we
support kubernetes compliance for what's
next we plan on getting to our 0.2
release that's going to happen this
summer and we have some focus around
getting to much easier setup right now
unfortunately it does require a little
bit of understanding of KC net and
native cube flow components we want to
make that very very easy for you to
start with second we really want to
focus on taking advantage of all the
work that the kubernetes community is
currently doing we want to abstract away
a number of the different components
including auto scaling improved
accelerators we want to make it so that
your data scientists can simply describe
declaratively what they would like to
have this job run as and kubernetes
takes care of all this stuff under the
hood we also want to support more
packages and frameworks while you saw a
demonstration with tensorflow
we have a number of folks in the
community who are already contributing
Pete white torch Cafe we've heard
requests for extra boost and a max net
and so on and so forth and we want to
support that as much as possible and in
particular if there are particular
scenarios that you're you're hearing
from or you'd like us to extend to we'd
love to hear that neck
and then finally you know the the best
feature that we like is the one that we
haven't heard yet it is a completely
open platform we have an open community
everything is done in the public via our
open source repository and it really is
an open design one of the things that we
learned best about kubernetes was really
listening to all the ways that people
wanted to use the platform that it
didn't yet support that helped us
understand the ways that we should
extend the places we should invest in
and how to do open new open ideas and
open source development and and we
really are open we have an open source
repo you can come in anytime you can
contribute
we have slack channels we have email
lists we have github with issues and we
want to hear more than anything what to
do next and while it is a 0.1 release
and maybe a little bit early for your
environment all the components that are
running inside it are battle-tested they
are tensorflow and Jupiter hub and
ambassador and Selden and tensorflow
serving these are things that have been
out in the wild for a long long time and
they are more than ready for it to
experiment with and give us feedback and
so with that you know I'm gonna wrap up
please stay tuned for the live Q&A
you
you
thank you very much and welcome back so
we have a lot of questions we'll try to
get through them all the first one
do you support other frameworks besides
tensorflow yes absolutely
we started with tensorflow because at
Google that's what we're familiar with
and that's what the team's already had
ready to go
we absolutely want to support other
frameworks we want to support every
framework we want to have them as native
packages that we test nightly and roll
them out and so more than anything we
are really looking for the community to
help us prioritize give us your feedback
and we will help bubble things to the
top as I mentioned we do have several
operators already checked in to the code
base that you can start experimenting
with right now but it is absolutely a
core of cube flow to support all the
frameworks the machine learning
frameworks that people would want can I
run cube flow outside of Google Cloud
absolutely as you saw we support all the
way from your laptop to any kubernetes
compliant cloud or a deployment so
whether or not that's your on-prem
hybrid google cloud another cloud as
long as it's kubernetes compliant it
should run great it's not we want to
hear about it because that is part of
our core mission how do I customize cube
flow so as you saw there are some
standard packages cube flow core and
others that run inside in our overall
registry we actually support a number of
different ways to configure it cube flow
uses case Anette from hep do to create
packages that are highly customizable
that use parameters and other things and
you can either download and tweak those
using parameters or the native extension
points or you can write there your own
and you don't have to submit those to a
central registry you can have your own
private registry that cube flow can use
or any of your team can use that's
appropriate for you what's the roadmap
for cube flow we expect as I mentioned
to hint 0.2 this summer and you know
shortly thereafter we expect to go
straight to 1.0 and our ga release you
know more than anything we want
to accelerate people's solutions with ml
and so for us as soon as we feel like we
can have that production ready
environment that actually solve
solutions today we're very excited to
hit one point out more than anything we
are ready to listen to you and so if it
if there are key features missing we
would love to hear about them if it
feels like all the features are that are
there and it's just a matter of
finishing off and getting everything
production ready we can focus on that
too so more than anything we'd love to
hear from you
do you support ml accelerators in cube
flow absolutely the machine learning
framework for cube flow has exceeded me
for kubernetes has done a bunch of work
relative to ml and ML accelerators this
has been with contributions from Google
from Nvidia from Intel a number of
different folks making sure that the way
to extend kubernetes is very
straightforward so you can pick and
choose the accelerators that are native
to you without having to do
customization without having necessarily
to run a different version of your
container runtime in order to support ml
or accelerators cube flow our goal is to
not do any of that stuff we want to
leverage all the work that the
kubernetes team is doing under the hood
and simply make it available via
annotations or higher level constructs
that you can describe your ml workloads
and say I'd like to roll this out and
I'd like to use this type of accelerator
here or I'd used like to use that type
of accelerator there and and kubernetes
will take care of the hard stuff under
the hood are there any detailed
tutorials on this on which you can deep
dive absolutely we have workshops
tutorials on github you know I I highly
recommend a number of walkthroughs and
videos that people have done I'd also
suggest going to our examples directory
we already have a number of different
really cool examples one we did in
partnership with the team from github
around doing github issue summarization
to make it very easy to understand
what's happening in larger github repos
that's all built on top of cube flow and
as you saw there it is
golde to make available a number of
different models just like you saw with
tensorflow
excuse me with tensor two tensor to make
it very straightforward to download
standard models and run them part of
what we're trying to do with cube flow
really is solve the reproducibility
crisis in in machine learning it is a
very common scenario where you might
have a machine learning scientist at one
organization who publishes their
research and it basically is impossible
for them to reproduce for any other data
scientist to reproduce that experiment
by you know our goal are the long-term
vision with cube flow is really solve
that and have everyone be able to
publish your cube flow code your bottle
and your data and and make that an
entire package that allows anyone to
reproduce a given machine learning
solution and so you'll see that over and
over and over again we are going out
there working with researchers and
machine learning data scientists to
figure out how to make that happen
finally when would I use cube flow over
cloud machine learning engine cloud
machine learning engine is an offering
from Google that is offers hosted
prediction and inference and the fact is
is that's exactly what cube flow is
designed to do machine learning engine
is a hosted solution so if you don't
want to think about scaling up or using
GPUs or not using GPUs worried about
serving or anything like that
it offers a fantastic endpoint for you
to upload your model and take care of
and and cloud machine learning engine
takes care of the rest
cube flow is highly composable we offer
an orchestration engine built in called
Argo from the Argo project which is also
open source and from that it offers a
number of different steps to walk
through all the components that you saw
on on some of those earlier slides in
any one of those steps you could say
actually I don't want to use the
component that was built into cube flow
I'd really prefer to use this hosted
software as a service just handle this
particular step and whether or not
that's training or inference or anything
along the lines you can
dropped cube flow to say okay you've
reached the step now call out to this
external service once you're done call
back to this web hook and I'm ready to
go and that really is it the idea is
that cube flow provides this more
general orchestration framework and
stack that you can swap in and out if
you want to customize or self host or do
something for yourself then use cube
flow if you'd like there to be a managed
solution that took care of everything
for you then you might use something
like machine learning engine for that
particular step and I shouldn't
reiterate that that is a key component
of cube flow we want to make it very
very easy for you to deploy and plug in
to your existing legacy applications and
so whether or not you already have a
data processing solution which is
extremely common you know arguably
anyone who's doing a certain amount of
data processing today or collecting a
certain amount of data today has some
data processing pipelines that's
fantastic as long as you're able to
surface that the processing of that data
to keep flow that's great
you don't have to run that particular
component inside cube flow you can
simply connect the components in cube
flow to that data processing pipeline
and it should run fine and so with that
we're wrapped up with all our cube flow
questions will be online and available
to answer any further questions or as
you saw with all of the community
framework and connection points you're
more than welcome to come and jump in
and ask us questions directly and we try
to be very very responsive with that
stay tuned for the next session cloud
armour protecting your application from
DDoS attacks with Google and thank you
very much for the time
you